White House press secretary Sean Spicer
just slipped into the cherry joins us
now in the East Room good morning mr.
Spicer I tried to keep Ivanka here much
better so training everybody well it's
great to have her but it's good to have
you oh it's good to see you thank you
boy they call you day times newest star
for the TV for your TV Fire exchanges
I'm wondering what it's like for you
Sean when you're sitting up there it's
intense
seems to be intense everyday though
someday there's a lot it's it's only one
piece of a day you know it's about 40
minutes a day the rest of it is a lot
calmer a lot more pleasant I think the
TV cameras intensify what goes on there
but the most of the exchanges are very
pleasant throughout the day you just
seeing one glimpse of what happened
you're still enjoying the job there's
all sorts of rumors about Willie stay
we're not that's a I feel very good look
and as you were just talking about being
here in the White House it truly is an
honor to have this job and I feel
humbled every day to have it to
represent the president the White House
and the American people so I love what I
do as long as the president wants me
around okay well he said you'll stick
around as long as there's great ratings
there well then keep tuning in yeah
obviously there's been some tension
between the press and the president
what's your suggestion from making that
relationship optimal I think the H has
their job to do you want the press to be
tough and you want an opportunity to
explain your own policies I think that's
right I think that that's the
fundamental aspect of what we're trying
to do we want to talk about what we're
doing they have a right and a duty
frankly to ask tough questions and get
to the bottom of things I think there's
a difference though about the tone that
occurs sometimes and an attempt to try
to get a headline rather than a story I
think that they they write the press or
the President or the press but we want
to make sure that that we we've and I
think you saw Jeff nation over the
weekend talk about how we've gone to
great lengths to be transparent
accessible and give the press and think
so a lot of the behind the scenes is not
you read all the time in terms of how we
operate we have we feel very good about
the relationship that exists and I
understand the press is always going to
want more access more transparency and
we do our best to make sure that they
have access to the president to leaders
throughout the White House and the
government but we want to make sure that
it's fair coverage and I think that's
where I think a lot of the tension comes
is when you take an issue out of context
or try to create a narrative that isn't
there but sometimes what you're saying
there at the podium doesn't appear to
drive with the facts of what's been
presented with whatever the issue is and
I'm wondering how you deal with that
well again we go up there every day
armed with a set of facts we have and
sometimes it becomes a game of gotcha
which is someone comes in and says well
I know this instead and that that's if
that's the game it's who can stump the
chump
then that's not really an a an exercise
in trying to get to the bottom of a
situation if it's trying to figure out
who can you know get the other person
that's one thing if it's an attempt to
really understand an issue we get up
there every day we do a lot of prep to
try to make sure that we've got all the
facts and the figures but if someone's
trying to figure out how they can have
they can sneak a fast one on us and say
did you know that line 78 of that bill
had this provision it well then that's
not an honest attempt to really
understand the news we're around all day
long the press briefings usually happen
at 1 o'clock and I'm always amazed
sometimes that a member of the press
corps that has sat on an issue for five
or six hours only because they want to
play a gotcha quite you know playing a
gotcha question if they're truly
interested in getting to the bottom of a
situation we'll be able to report out a
story I applaud that but the question
sometimes you have to ask is what's the
motive behind the tone and the question
they're asking Sean Spicer great to have
you thank you guys
are you watching melissa mccarthy movies
no how are you sick of it no I
laughing with it already you know
I enjoy this job very much and I there's
some there's it's it's fortunate when
someone tells you they're praying for
you're thinking of you your family but
there's also there can be a little bit
of criticism because as well and guess
what Vice President Mike Pence has also
worked hard to work to advance the
President's agenda and he's going to
join us coming up